you know in the last two episodes I
really realized how close were coming to
actually finishing this park and I know
I've said this before and but I still
didn't realize it myself how much of a
difference that one episode of doing
foliage makes to actually making the
right look so much more finished and now
i think i'm not even gonna make episode
69 with just this Pike and I'm still
thinking about what I'm going to do for
the next park because there are a couple
of ideas which I kind of want to do of
course there's that one idea that I was
going to make an Asian theme park but I
don't think that's going to happen in
the end because one park with just one
theme which is kind of what happened in
this park is usually not the best idea
for a really big park even Verona valley
had some although they were all in the
same timeline it had some different
areas with slightly different themes and
there are still slight differences in
this one too and what I might want to
try is the thing I've talked about
before is that I open multiple parks and
in each park I'm gonna build a park with
one theme and then combine all of those
parks and just um yeah well basically
assume thats one point that's what we're
all just going to imagine and but I
don't know if I really want to do that
because one idea which I've had for many
years and some other people have tried
to but I don't think it's ever really
been a huge success is to try and make a
floating park and I'm actually serious
about this because I don't know it's
always been an idea that really appeal
to me but I never really did it because
it's just undoable it's really hard to
do that the idea is you've got a couple
of floating islands preferably up in the
sky or something like that above the
clouds if you will and that's where you
place all the rides on and you have like
bridges in between the floating islands
and they basically made out big rocks
and only the surface on top is used
actually built right on I know it really
seems like something I want to try and I
think it would look really great but
it's kind of hard to pull off so I'm
kind of debating whether i should try
that for my newest park or just a
regular normal on earth and a
quote-unquote realistic park and i don't
know which of the two i'm going to do
and the thing is though if i'm not going
to make that floating park I definitely
do want to make a floating roller
coaster because I just wanted I just
want to do that sometime it's really an
amazing thing but anyway I need to talk
about what I'm doing right now I
finished I know what no I didn't finish
anything what am I talking about I
decided to add foliage to this ride not
because I think it's finished quite yet
it could use us more details and now you
might be thinking more details aren't
there enough details for you already and
the simple answer to that is no the
longer answer to that is yeah yeah sure
but not quite as many as i would have
liked you know there's something with
just scattering the ground with random
boxes and chests and barrels and oil
drums that nobody really appreciates but
then again it looks really awesome and
it just I don't know it's kind of stupid
sometimes this is the kind of theme
where you built the buildings they built
the foliage and you built the rides but
that's not everything you need to build
random [ __ ] as well so placing random
chests and barrels might be an annoyance
sometimes it's still cool to do and it
still does make the entire thing look
better so that's definitely something
that I still need to do but that's
absurd i do all this foliage work of
course and there's rock work to cover up
this these awkward edges of this pond
you know this has always been a problem
for me because every time I make a pond
or is something similar up comes the
debate of whether you should lower the
water level 1 H or whether you should
just keep it the same height as the
surface and the advantage to this is
that the water is not going to be quite
as far away or as um yeah well yeah
you're not gonna have like 1h cliff
faces which is not something you'd
really want to have with a pond and that
fountain was absolutely terrible but if
you don't kind of sink it in then you
get these
edges which you're going to have to
cover with rock work oh well raka looks
kind of good at that I think there are
many things in this park that really
sucks that just need to be covered up by
rocks because seriously rocks are good
at that extremely good if you have a
ride and there are some parts and it's
like terraforming and you know parts and
terraforming they don't go very well
together and you get like these awkward
click faces and you don't want that rock
work you can cover it up with the rock
work if you have some awkward waterfront
and you know the what is kind of like
you mayhem in like the side of the lake
it's not really smooth or anything
you'll rock rock work just cover it up
with rocks that's basically the solution
to every landscaping thing that doesn't
look really good you can just place
rocks on it the same goes for foliage
though when it comes to rocks if you've
got a rock and it doesn't look that good
and you're like all right this look
different in my head looked or better in
my head but now that I've place the
rocks it looks like [ __ ] you can just
cover it with foliage if your foliage is
not good on the other hand you're going
to have a bit of a problem and that's
why foliage is also very important I
mean foliage just makes everything more
clean it divides areas it can fill up
the emptiness where you need to do that
it can fill up the ugliness with
beautifulness if you really need to do
that and that's why i love foliage
though these things are really amazing
these like little grants things I mean
we don't have actual grass in roller
coaster second three for many reasons
people have actually built many custom
scenery sites for grass but I don't
think any of the set really came out of
a beta I know that some people do have
some beta sets of grass sets but never
really worked and they don't really use
it because it's it either doesn't look
very realistic it will never be the No
Limits grass or the real life growth of
course but it is also often way too high
poly I mean these small little grass
patches already create a huge amount of
lags your legs noise and actually
as you may know I've got an NVIDIA GTX
970 video card which is ridiculously
high that's one of the newer add
graphics card out there one of the best
best graphics cards on the market and i
zoom out on this bike and I got seven
frames per second with eight gigs of ram
so yeah rolla kousaka three you're great
I I can actually get 800 FPS on
minecraft but yeah so basically roller
coaster can three like 200 times more
than Mycroft I'm at is great that is
absolutely fantastic oh well it probably
still runs better than call of duty
ghosts though it might not that would be
extremely terrible you know what you
know what I do realize though the more
you look at this foliage it's very
diverse and it's way more diverse than
any foliage in real life would be
seriously and perhaps rollercoaster
second three is kind of like I don't
know I don't want to quote a clockwork
orange but they were talking about how
on video everything looks more realistic
than in real and I think in Raleigh co
second three it's the same story with
foliage it's like roller coasters icon
three foliage only actually looks real
if you exaggerate it if you make it much
more ridiculous than real life foliage
because in real life you just have a
couple of trees and boring trees around
the ride with some boring phones and
nothing is actually interesting and
there are no flowers or different colors
it's all just met but then I roller
comes second three you place all of
these different trees and only then will
look realistic if you if you actually do
the realistic thing and place the same
old tree over and over again throughout
the park which is more realistic or at
least I'm on a small scale it just looks
less realistic in rolla go sick in 3d
and I suppose that's something to keep
in mind that sometimes over the top is
actually better than ultra realism and
actually looks more realistic and of
course more beautiful and I don't know
is there such if it's there such a thing
as detail overkill think it depends on
what theme you're working with but in
general I'd rather have detail overkill
then
well barely any detail but that's just
my opinion on that matter in the next
episode I'm going to work on this small
little antsy a far ride which I've
called the wiggly wah blow for now but
that's definitely not going to be the
name so see you then